un histórico avance para los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos en méxico tras
dos días de debates la corte suprema de
justicia declaró inconstitucional la
penalización del aborto a partir de
ahora no se podrá sin violar el criterio
de la corte y la constitución procesar a
mujer alguna que aborte en los supuestos
que ha considerado válido este tribunal
constitucional
el fallo anula por unanimidad varias
disposiciones de una ley del estado de
coahuila al norte del país que había
convertido el aborto en un acto criminal
la decisión no sólo revierte la ley sino
que también sienta un precedente
obligatorio para todos los jueces del
país pero vamos a agradecer porque vamos
a salvar ellos vidas y vamos a tener
políticas públicas que nos permitan a
las mujeres seguir atendiéndolos con
seguridad ciertas organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos
celebraron la decisión y reconocieron
que es un logro del movimiento feminista
mexicano uno de los más grandes en
américa latina' celebramos la decisión
de las y los ministros de la suprema
corte de justicia de la nación de
declarar inconstitucional la
penalización del aborto en mexico este
importante avance de derechos humanos es
también un logro de diversos movimientos
feministas mujeres y personas gestantes
jon sin embargo frente al recinto de la
corte varias personas contrarias a la
interrupción del embarazo manifestaron
su inconformidad no es la solución el
aborto con las soluciones ayudarlas
comprenderlas
para auxiliarlas mucho para llevar este
ese bebé que nazca en mexico el aborto
solo está despenalizado en 4 de los 32
estados panorama que se podría revertir
de usar el precedente de este martes
para combatir por la vía judicial la
criminalización del aborto en otras
partes del país